let's see let me get up the Xiaomi
online nice and juicy
[Music]
order up let's go get in line
hi my name is Jake Dell I'm the fifth
generation owner here at Katz's Deli on
the Lower East Side in New York City so
we've been here 129 years it's been the
same mobile system for 129 years after
you get your ticket you're gonna get to
rest in mine that's what you do next if
you lose your ticket
we bring you to Katz's jail which is in
the basement we turn you into a piece of
astronomy
that's what all the flavoring in know
what you want by the time you get up to
the front of the counter cause we will
yell at you but otherwise don't be
scared we're very nice yes the perfect
order if you got a couple people you
kind of divide and conquer will you go
like to the grill you get a couple hot
dogs it's perfect appetizer
while you're waiting on line for a
sandwich mustard and crowd is the only
way to eat a hotdog
you know we maintain the classic we make
everything ourselves we cure everything
ourselves and smoke everything ourselves
you get a pastrami nice and juicy and
someone goes down and gets the latkes
and y'all meet in the middle of the
table we have a feast what can be better
a preterite cancer there's an artist
somebody's been doing this for many
years no one's a cutter overnight we
start on the floor you then you work on
the grill and you kind of learn those
knife skills ultimately becoming a
skilled meat Carver will do you know
40,000 pounds of meat every week we are
the oldest delicatessen not just in New
York City but in the world and so we do
everything the classic way the way that
Bobby would have done the way that your
grandma would have done and we like to
mean payment
instead of doing 250 latkes like we
normally do let's do it one mica so we
got a couple of potatoes here already
ground up my grandmother taught me how
to make it what she taught me was to use
your hands everything should be about
feel and not at all about actual
measurements the amount of flour we're
gonna add is we're just gonna keep
adding it until it's roughly the right
consistency I actually thought I was
gonna be a doctor to be honest I guess I
went from cutting people so cutting me I
think that's a pretty good switch off so
the other thing that my grandmother was
a fan of was the way that you sprinkle
it on
she felt salt had to go one direction
and pepper had to go the other way
one of the main things is how it comes
through your fingers right you want it
to kind of just drip down like that
that's the best feeling beautiful nice
work Curnow i walk in the doors in their
days right like it hits you you know
you're like what we're doing here is
something special it's hard to really
pinpoint what it is that makes us so
special but you feel it when you walk in
here I feel humbled by it every every
day that I walked in here you're gonna
get the best sandwiches you've ever had
you're gonna get the best lockers you've
ever had you're gonna get the best matzo
ball soup you've ever had it's also the
tradition you know they're old using
your hands tradition it's the
Baljit - it's that emotional connection
that people have to this place every
minute we manage to stay true to who we
are and there's always been at least one
person at the helm that was been
interested in quality and I think that's
what really set us apart from one of the
other places and I think it's just the
atmosphere is fun it's a cool place I
mean no matter what time you come it's
just fun and and it's crazy and it's
boisterous and I think that that energy
has allowed us to really withstand the
test of time it's very lucky it's very
very lonely to be a part of this
what's more New York senator right I
haven't shown now actually to even see
it cooking with that schmuck
[Music]